♪ ♪
>> Sean: NOW ELECTION DAY IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE RECALL IS THIS COMING
TUESDAY.
AND DEMOCRATS ARE DESPERATE.
THEY ARE PULLING OUT EVERY STOP
TO TRY TO SAVE GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM FROM A MASSIVE POLITICAL
UPSET.
HOLLYWOOD, BIG TECH, MAJOR
UNIONS, ALONG WITH LESSEE,
BARACK OBAMA, KAMALA HARRIS,
EVEN THE IMPLODING JOE BIDEN
PRAISE TO GAVIN NEWSOM.
BEGGING PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA,
KEEP THEM IN OFFICE DESPITE HIS
MASSIVE FAILURES, HE IS GIVEN
CHECKS TO ABOUT TWO-THIRDS OF
THE PEOPLE IN ALL OF CALIFORNIA
AND A TIME OF RECALL ELECTION,
TIMING IS A LITTLE BIT DUBIOUS
TO ME, NOW JOE BIDEN WILL BE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH
GOVERNOR NEWSOM ON MONDAY.
REMEMBER THAT HE ACTUALLY SAID
HE WAS SO PROUD OF BIDEN
ADMITTED THE AFGHAN EXIT DEBACLE
AND THE ABANDONING OF AMERICANS,
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT ON THE
WEST COAST.
AND HERE'S A QUESTION, WHY
HASN'T THERE BEEN WIDESPREAD
CONDEMNATION OF THE RECENT EGG
ATTACKED ON LARRY ELDER IN
LOS ANGELES WHICH THE L.A.
SHERIFF NOW SAYS LOOKS LIKE A
HATE CRIME.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED EARLIER
THIS WEEK, TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S GOING UP.
>> DO SOMETHING.
>> [BLEEP].
>> OKAY.
[INDISTINGUISHABLE]
>> [BLEEP], [BLEEP], [BLEEP].
>> YOU WILL HIT HIM.
>> [BLEEP].
>> HEY, KEEP AWAY.
>> [BLEEP] BOY.
>> GET THAT OUT OF HERE.
[BLEEP].
OKAY, STOP.
>> [BLEEP].
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION,
LARRY ELDER WHO IS NOW LEADING
BY DOUBLE DIGITS, WELL, THEY
MISSED BY A MILE WITH THE EGG,
SO, THAT'S GOOD NEWS, YOU KNOW,
DID ANYONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
TOOK A SWING ADDS, I BELIEVE
SOMEBODY THAT WAS A PART OF YOUR
SECURITY DETAIL, DID THEY GET
ARRESTED?
DID ANYBODY GET ARRESTED FOR THE
ATTEMPTED ASSAULT ON THE THEM?
>> NOT SO FAR, AS HE POINTED OUT
THE L.A. COUNTY SHERIFF SAID
CHALLENGING THE WOKE MEDIA, IF
THIS HAD BEEN DND, THEY WOULD
CAUSE IT A HATE CRIME AND TALK
ABOUT HOW IT IS SYSTEMIC RACISM,
BUT THIS IS THE MEDIA DOUBLE
STANDARD EVER SINCE I HAVE BEEN
RUNNING.
THERE WAS AN ALLEGATION THAT
LARRY ELDER DOES NOT LIKE WOMEN
BASED ON SOME 21-YEAR-OLD
ARTICLE WHERE I WAS QUOTING A
LEFT-WING ORGANIZATION.
AND I BELIEVE SOME ALLEGATION
ENGAGING IN AN ACT OF VIOLENCE
AGAINST A WOMAN WHICH I
VEHEMENTLY DENIED.
BUT THE OTHER OUTLETS RAN WITH
THAT FOR DAYS AND DAYS AND DAYS.
AN ALLEGATION MADE BY ROSE
McGOWAN, THE ONE WHO WAS
DESTROYED BECAUSE SHE REFUSED TO
SLEEP WITH HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
IT WAS BECAUSE OF
HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND OTHER
ALLEGATIONS, FACING A SERIES OF
RAPE CHARGES.
JUST YESTERDAY, SAID THE WIFE OF
GAVIN NEWSOM CALLED HER ON
BEHALF OF HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
LAWYER.
AND SAID BEFORE THAT REALLY BLEW
UP, HOW CAN WE MAKE YOU HAPPY?
HOW CAN THE STORY GO AWAY?
I'M ROSE McGOWAN EVEN PRODUCED
EMAILS FROM GAVIN NEWSOM'S WIFE
THAT THEY HAD THE CORRESPONDENT.
WHETHER THE STORY IS TRUE OR
FALSE, I KNOW AN ALLEGATION WAS
MADE THAT MY SIGNIFICANT OTHER
ON BEHALF OF HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
LAWYER CALLED ROSE McGOWAN AND
TRY TO GET HER TO BACK OFF THE
STORY, THAT'S ALL THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
NOW THEY HAVE THE STORY, CNN HAD
THE STORY, WE KNOW THEY HAVE THE
STORY, BUT THEY HAVE NOT
REPORTED ON IT AT ALL.
REAL POLITICS DID, NEWSTEAD,
MAKING THE ALLEGATION HERE ON
YOUR PROGRAM.
WHERE'S THE INVESTIGATION?
WHERE IS THE INVESTIGATIVE
JOURNALIST?
WHERE'S JOURNALISM?
>> Sean: WE HAVE SEEN THE
HYPOCRISY.
GAVIN NEWSOM, RESTAURANTS
CLOSING DOWN, HE IS IN
RESTAURANT, NO OTHER
RESTAURANTS, KIDS IN PUBLIC
SCHOOL, HIS WINERY STAYS OPEN,
AND NOW HE IS GIVING OUT CHECKS.
WE HAVE 30 SECONDS, HOW DO YOU
TIME THE CHECKS TO 16 -- IS IT
60 PLUS PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS
JUST BEFORE THE RECALL?
IS THAT TRUE?
>> YEAH, ALL OF A SUDDEN THE NEW
POLL COMES OUT, THE REPORT --
RECALL IS IN THE MARGIN OF
ERROR, ASKING THEM TO VOTE YES
ON THE RECALL, SIGN YOUR BALLOT,
IF YOU DON'T TRUST THE MAIL, YON
FOLLOW IT ONLINE OR DROP IT OFF
AT A VOTING CENTER AND THEN GO
TO ElectDaily.com .
IF YOU SEE ANYTHING SUSPICIOUS
WE HAVE A LAWYER, VOTE YES ON
THE RECALL, AND
ElectElder.com .
MY OPPOSING HAS SPENT 75,000
ALREADY AND WILL PROBABLY SPEND
A MILLION.
>> Sean: I BELIEVE IN
MIRACLES, ALAN MICHAELS, DO YOU
BELIEVE IN MIRACLE